[Music]
tonight studying new revelations on
anti-trump bias at the FBI as you know
two top agents removed from Muller's
Russia investigation exchanged tens of
thousands of texts many of them
disparage President Trump who they were
investigating according to two lawmakers
Peter struck and Lisa Paige also spoke
of a secret society formed at the FBI
after mr. Trump's election the day after
the election the day after what they
really really didn't want to have happen
there's a text exchanged between these
two FBI agents these two supposed to be
objective facts centric FBI agents
saying perhaps this is the first meeting
of the secret society so of course I'm
going to want to know what secret
society are you talking about because
you're supposed to be investigating
objectively the person who just won the
electoral college so yeah I'm gonna want
to know mm-hmm five months worth of text
between the pair have gone mi a the
FBI's lost them the president calls it
one of the biggest stories in a long
time the Justice Department insists it
will get to the bottom of it but here's
one that wasn't lost it shows struck
expressing skepticism the Muller probe
would uncover any wrongdoing by the
president and his team quote my gut
sense and concerned there's no big there
there Sarah Sanders was asked about the
president's thoughts on these new
developments just moments ago I think he
thinks that there's a great cause for
concern that five months worth of text
messages have gone missing particularly
given the individual that has part of
that process has already been shown to
be extremely biased against the
president and was involved in what seems
to be some very inappropriate behavior
and that certainly is a great concern
okay and speaking of secret societies
clearly there is one between dana perino
myself
in shades of purple one is like one
honorary member I got the memo I'm
trying to match Greg's head it looks
better today by the way I hope it does
it's makeup maybe it'll radically change
your personality the little bump okay
all right Dana so what do you
like the emails gone investigation going
forward strong statements from the AG
and now mention of a secret society well
and I don't know I I don't make too much
out of any of it because I think that
all of its coming out in little pieces
you don't know what the context is and
there are people that are pushing a
particular agenda that might say well
this obviously means this it could
actually mean something else we don't
know the fact I've been at the White
House at a time when there were emails
that were on a server that went missing
and it's like there was a technical
problem and where they were and it
caused a huge hullabaloo for a long time
they ultimately were found and I think
that the FBI having the tools that it
has probably will be able to find them
and Richard Burr the Senate Intelligence
Committee Chairman he said that he
doesn't think there was anything
nefarious that it was technical maybe
that's true maybe it's not I don't know
and then you have the point that the
email that you just read or the text
where he says a struct says I don't
really think there's anything there
there that would seem to support the
president's position that there is no
collusion so it's just really very much
all over the map and I'm just gonna wait
to make any conclusions until there is
some sort of conclusion by everyone else
Jesse often are you just sitting in awe
of Dana's reasonable and not wait for
any conclusion I'm gonna I'm gonna make
more out of this looks to me like
there's rogue federal agents trying to
corrupt the justice system and undermine
American democracy if you have FBI
agents texting about brushing up on
Watergate and impeachment right after
Trump's election and you have a talk
about it's a secret society between FBI
agents and justest officials who were
the same people talking about creating
an insurance policy to protect the
country against the election of Donald
Trump that seems pretty sketchy to me
and these are the same people now are
working on the Muller team before they
were fired now also the counter
intelligence and counter FB an espionage
agent of the FBI was tapped to be on the
Muller team and the first thing that
comes to his mind is there's no there
there there's
no collusion I mean that says a lot
because that's his job that's his
wheelhouse right there and so he gets
put into that position
they don't really find any collusion so
far and now it looks like an obstruction
of justice case that they're making and
who is the chief witness for obstruction
of justice it's James Comey the best
friend for Robert Muller so he illegally
leaks the memo to his buddy the
professor up you know a few blocks away
at Columbia and now Comey hires his
buddy the professor to represent him as
his personal attorney so that locks down
the professor's testimony very cagey and
then all of a sudden the FBI techs go
missing visit the FBI their entire job
is to retain intelligence and then they
lost the intelligence from the critical
time period when this investigation
began it doesn't make sense and then
today the chief of staff for James
coming and the current FBI director ray
resigns all of a sudden it's I'm willing
to make a little bit more of it than
Dana Perino but she's always been more
cautious all right well Jesse making hey
so what do you say well I'm gonna try to
make as much sense as possible which
means I will make no sense
I enjoyed the scandal ping-pong of all
of this so every time some entity pushes
the Russian collusion narrative it pops
up then the FBI DOJ Clinton cover-up
comes right back it's like the Trump
clip critics are relieving themselves in
the wind and it feels good at the moment
but then they end up all wet yeah there
you go thank you
but detect that you know the text
between these two FBI agents they it
does reflect what we always knew when we
what we saw a visceral and emotional
reaction to Donald Trump people hated
him so much and still do that it they
feel justified to do anything because
their sense of righteousness made it
okay greater if they were like they date
it may gave them the greater purpose and
then you have you throw into that the
romance of it so they're they're like
they're in love they're having an affair
their poor spouses and so it's like you
can hear David Bowie's heroes in the
background as they talk about it's a two
against us and they're there's a secret
society
a treehouse down by the river with
secret handshakes and it goes I go back
to what always my place of wisdom which
is the Brady Bunch
mom always said never play ball in the
house yeah and this is what happens when
you play ball in the house yeah it's
true it's true they played ball in the
house and on the government a Brady
Bunch yesterday yeah you know what I did
I got it I got Marcia Brady in my face
but a lot of this noise this conspiracy
stuff exists because it can America is a
resilient country the economy's
barreling along so we can go on and on
and on about this as America goes on
it's like it's almost as though the
media like we're watching a Netflix
series we're almost done
you know but but the media is still
stuck on the first episode they can't
move on from this stuff they're just
spinning their wheels because it's just
they just they can't let go don't play
ball in the house all right well it
seems like you've got some energy you're
doing better today no I thank God for
prescription medications
okay so just some other ones as usual
what do you make of these occurrence of
developments well you know breaking news
here on the Fox News Channel nobody
mentions it but apparently the Attorney
General was interviewed by Robert Muller
oh my gosh this is the first time a
Trump cabinet secretary has been
interviewed by the special counsel not
only that another breaking news event
Jim Comey interviewed by the special
counsel robert muller meanwhile what
we've learned is that's for here for
yeah you know our news here on Fox guess
what you know it's unbelievable
apparently the Attorney General has been
pressuring Christopher Rea the FBI
director to go after Andrew McCabe the
number-two guy and guess what the Trump
nominee the Trump guy at FBI said to the
Trump Attorney General if you want this
done get somebody else in here he didn't
say he was going to quit but he said
he'd have somebody else do it
oh my gosh so what do we have here we
have a picture a picture of the Trump
administration right now on its heels
and fighting to muddy up dirty discredit
the FBI and robber
smaller meanwhile Muller is having
stepped up activity and it's driving not
only towards the possibility of
collusion but also towards obstruction
of justice and at this moment what do
you get a counter-attack from the Trump
Stooges on Capitol Hill fujas imagine
that two people having an affair are
texting each other and imagine that
people inside the FBI have opinions
about ongoing investigations as if that
is now a reason to say the FBI you know
is like a horse cage and needs to be
cleaned up again so guess what one I
guess the collision only matters if it's
somebody you don't like if you don't
like that person then it's collusion but
if you like that person it's a choice
for president
then you'll ignore any real collusion
which is admitting it before that there
was no Russian collusion that there was
that Lynch knew ahead of time that there
were thousands of texts Lawson that
there's a secret society but that's not
collusion because you like Hillary know
if there was collusion I would be all
with you but I'm just saying even at
this moment
I wish brought today to read that some
Democrats are concerned about the impact
the Russia is having right now in the
midst of the course they are in the next
they're saying in the midst of the
argument over the daca program guess
what we've seen increased activity by
these robos yes Democrats didn't care
about Russia during the Cold War now all
of a sudden they care so much the death
with the Russian communists the
Democrats were caving and they were
appeasing now when Russia is not a
threat all of a sudden whatever the Cold
War I mean to say this to you
Jesse yes Chris ray yes what do you
think you trust him I trust anybody that
keeps emails and texts where the text go
wisely so you say Hillary I see you they
got the same place the IRS you know
screaming is not an effective
I have to go to my secret society Paul
DiMaggio Danny Perino for the final word
to clean this mess up well there's a lot
of smoke coming from a lot of different
directions where there's smoke there's a
lot of fire people learn that in
investigations all the time like former
Governor Chris Christie for example like
basically had Bridgegate come down fall
upon him like a ton of bricks and
basically ruin his chances for a future
political office so yeah things can
happen along the way but these
investigations take a lot of time and it
is sort of like Americans turning tune
in to the news because it is almost
entertainment now yeah so we expect
something new every day so I think
that's why you have these different
entities pushing one narrative and then
oh yeah well you if you're gonna put up
the thing about the missing text I'll
put out there that the Moller
investigation interviewed the Attorney
General and the former FBI director so
now we can equally see then they're all
equal like you can't they're all like
it's like you know pros and cons each
one's equal they need to have a
lost-and-found for missing text
somebody's got to invent that like I
lost fifty thousand texts surely
somebody could find those it's the size
of a small car we're missing if they
don't know how many are missing they had
50,000 that they've reviewed I thought
there was 15,000 missing I should
probably read more closely it doesn't
really matter it could be it could be a
hundred thousand texts it's probably a
half a million well you are injured and
could cause potentially we'll have a cat
scan and get back to